man
they got uh they got their jerseys right
here obviously and then what's that
come on in tell them to come on in here
let's see y'all come on in so this is
[Laughter]
this is pretty special man
i've been thinking about this number for
a long time i even got it on my shoes so
uh
basketball history this is pretty
special um
i mean like i said these two you know
legends uh
i watched it watch them growing up and
understood what it meant to shoot the
ball because of them and my dad and
uh full circle moment man i'm just i'm
blessed blessed for sure no it was a it
was a special night we were glad to be
witnesses to it and uh again nice going
nice going stefan you're here at the top
of the mountain
appreciate it thank you very much
congratulations my favorite player pre
appreciate shaq yes sir he makes it look
stupid
yes he does
oh man
this was uh this was just i mean start
to finish this is just a special night
shay special night we knew he was going
to do it fabulous player great player
just
you know to see those guys celebrate
with them it's you know just an honor
now to hear reggie say so reluctantly
steph curry is the greatest shooter of
all time you all know me i'm petty white
i would i would have problems saying
somebody else is a better big man but
kudos to reggie and ray and you know
steph he's my favorite player because
i've never seen anybody shoot
at the magnitude that that you know he
does so i'm happy for staff i'm happy
for his family happy for those guys and
uh
it can only happen here on tnt game
recognized game doesn't it kenny yeah
game recognizes game he is the
greatest shooter in the nba history
because of this
he can do it on a catch and shoot he can
do it on a
down screen for a pick and he can do it
off the dribble and if you look at all
the greatest shooters they were one-way
shooters they were either catch and
shoot or they shot off the dribble or
they catch off a pick this